news daily from science mission during  heart attack mitochondrial calcium  importer MCU rushes too much calcium  into the mitochondria and cause cells to  die scientist in the journal p ensure  that in mice without MCU no calcium rush  into the mitochondria but cell still die  since alternative pathways are activated  thus targeting MCU for drug development  to treat heart attack may not be a good  strategy next it is not known how the  genes get up regulated specifically in  neurons during development authors in  the journal Nature communications show  that micro RNA mere nine down regulates  rna-binding protein rich tetra prolene  TTP levels thereby increasing the  expression of necessary genes in the  neurons and decreasing their knee  gradation while in this non-neuronal  cells TTP blocks expression of neural  jeans because Mira nine does not block  their function for more news visitors as  www science mission calm or science  mission Facebook page thanks for  watching